i had therefore to remove knowledge in
order to make room for belief
seek not the favor of the multitude it
is seldom god by honest and lawful means
but seek the testimony of few and number
not voices but weigh them
thoughts without content or empty
intuitions without concepts are blind
it is beyond a doubt that all our
knowledge that begins with experience
science is organized knowledge wisdom is
organized life
experience without theory is blind but
theory without experience is mere
intellectual play
intuition and concepts constitute the
elements of all our knowledge so that
neither concepts without an intuition in
some way corresponding to them nor
intuition without concepts can yield
knowledge
all our knowledge begins with the senses
proceeds then to the understanding and
ends with reason
there is nothing higher than reason
but although all our knowledge begins
with experience it does not follow that
it arises from experience
immaturity is the incapacity to use
one's intelligence without the guidance
of another
a categorical imperative would be one
which represented an action is
objectively necessary in itself without
reference to any other purpose
two things on me most the starry sky
above me and the moral law within me
it is not necessary that whilst i live i
live happily but it is necessary that so
long as i live i should live honorably
morality is not the doctrine of how we
may make ourselves happy but how we may
make ourselves worthy of happiness
so act that your principle of action
might safely be made a law for the whole
world
in law a man is guilty when he violates
the rights of others
in ethics he is guilty if he only thinks
of doing so
from such crooked wood as that which man
is made of nothing straight can be
fashion
live your life as though your every act
were to become a universal law
may you live your life as if the maxim
of your actions were to become a
universal law
religion is the recognition of all our
duties as divine commands
nothing is divine but what is agreeable
to reason
it is not god's will merely that we
should be happy but that we should make
ourselves happy
to be as to do
all thought must directly or indirectly
by way of certain characters relate
ultimately to intuitions and therefore
with us to sensibility because in no
other way can an object be given to
us happiness is not an ideal of reason
but of imagination
by a lie a man annihilates his dignity
as a man
even philosophers will praise war as
ennobling mankind forgetting the greek
who said war is bad in that it begets
more evil than it kills
ingratitude is the essence of vileness
if a man makes himself a worm he must
not complain when he is trodden on
metaphysics is a dark ocean without
shores or lighthouse strewn with many a
philosophic wreck
always recognize that human individuals
are ends and do not use them as means to
your end
what can i know what ought i to do
what can i hope
he who is cruel to animals becomes hard
also in his dealings with men we can
judge the heart of a man by his
treatment of animals
the only objects of practical reason are
therefore those of good and evil
for by the former is meant an object
necessarily desired according to a
principle of reason by the latter one
necessarily shunned also according to a
principle of reason
[Music]
you